THE GAME IS ON.
THE BRUINS
NOW AROUND THE BOARDS
AND  TAKE IT AWAY
AND WITH
THE PUCK THAT JUST
FINDS HIM AT THE TOP
OF THE CREASE H.
AND PATRICE BERGERON
CLOSING WITH THE
STNO PUCK AND IT'S
A PERFECT EXAMPLE.
CATCHING THE EDGEWHO
>> THEY REALIZED NO R
STICK THAT THEY WANT
TO ATTACK HIM WITH
SEAN MONAHAN THE SHOT O
AROUND THE BOARD.
AND WITH
TURNS OVER NOW LATE
THE COULD GET YOUR
ATTENTION  TO THIS ONE.
AND THIS 80 JAKE
DEBRUSK  IS
THE NUMBER ONE
GOALTENDER AND THE
SHOT WICE-OFF LOSS.
WITH THE SHOT ON AND AN
DOES NOT GET MUCH ON
IT.
OFF THE CLASS.
CHRISTOPHER TANEV
WITH THE SH
THIS IS THE GREAT
SAVE ON THE SIDE OF
THE NET.
SCOOPING IT UP
THEY GET BACK TO MAKE
IT TWO ON TWO.
PLAYS IN ATTACK MODE
MENTALITY.
AND THEN